[Music]
so there I was woke up with a heavy case
of amnesia in the middle of nowhere the
only clue to my past is Harry's name and
address inside this hat so I made my way
to be partnered and that's what I found
you
thank your stapler Colusa nation so your
otaku Pikachu with no memories is
addicted to caffeine I could stop
whenever I want these are just choices
another round extra shot I don't know
maybe hair got in too deep and mixed up
the wrong crowd that kind of thing you
could talk to humans I can talk to
Pokemon and if you want to find your
pops we're gonna need you no I don't
need a Pokemon what about a world-class
detective Harry is still alive case
closed
but still open until I solve it all
right here it is Harry faked his own
death or somebody else faked Terry's
death
[Music]
yeah Harry fake somebody else is dead
that last one doesn't work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now obviously I've dealt with this pups
before so I'll just do it again hey bud
what are you doing I can't do when
people are watching
[Music]
that's a twist
no he's barely moving don't tell him
that oh he's on a fight quick get in
front of him stop oh no he's going down
hard Tim should have worn a helmet
I see trees of green
red roses too I see them bloom
[ __ ] me
and I think to myself
[Music]
what I wonderful
the colors of the rainbow
so pretty in the sky are also on the
faces
[Music]
listen kid I know this much if your dad
was here
he'll hug you so hard your bones with
Papa
[Music]
[Applause]
I think to myself
what I wonder
to mark
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so let me get this right we're forced to
listen to this spa music so your head
doesn't explode and kill us all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Flareon
[Music]
in my head I saw that differently
Pokemon detective Pikachu only in
theaters May 10 rated PG come in there
whoever you are and know how to use this
geez
here we go when I first heard about the
detective Pikachu I was excited to do a
film that my kids would love and then I
could watch with them I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you
detective Petey she's got some sass he's
got some serious attitude he's kind of a
larger-than-life character and he has to
be I mean he looks like a little yellow
cotton ball toe I'm trying to bring as
much personality out to the character as
I possibly can
did you just talk oh my god you can
understand me I've been so lonely
this contradiction I've seems too cuddly
thing happened little bingo it's
incredible you can hear him right you're
adorable they can't understand me
kitchen no one else hear him in rhyme
city humans and pokémon lived side by
side as partners tim meets pick at your
hand slowly starts opening up what is it
silent but deadly
apologies my tummy's bashful on the
coffee you never seen this kind of
interaction before you can feel Pikachu
you can tell what Pikachu would be like
in real life you want to reach out touch
up and cuddle up the cuddle
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine
yeah tell us what we want to know pipe
yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving who's saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop
you're good cop no no we're not cops in
my head I saw that differently you want
to find your pot I'm your best bet it's
a new way of seeing Pokemon
but you have the magic you have the
iconic characters
something like this is free spam
whoa
[Music]
you found yourself a Pokemon partner
what happens I'm a world-class detective
you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet let's do this
no no we're not doing that fine I'll
walk I'm trying to get in a hundred
thousand steps this hour okay Mon
detective Pikachu your childhood bed as
a Pikachu bet I've never been so
flattered and creeped out at the same
time waited BG only in theaters May 10
you know I lived in a breathed and I
became the character I spent the entire
year as detective Pikachu
bringing detective Pikachu to the big
screen is a privilege that I don't take
lightly
every second and my energy is spent
making this character come alive with
the same exacting standards that the
most discerning fans would have come to
expect now as many of you know I vanish
into my roles there's a funny anecdote I
was I was on my way to pick up my
daughters from school when I heard that
I got the role well I didn't show up at
school because detective Pikachu he
doesn't know who those two little girls
are who are they they're our daughters
he just he just left them he doesn't
have a wife no he's a little yellow guy
there's a rhyme city in a briar patch or
something I immerse myself completely
within the world of Pokemon I read about
him I live at his height I tried to lose
a hundred and eighty two pounds to match
his weight until doctors intervened I
mean he didn't even change his voice it
just it just sounds like him the point
is my daughter's they may never see
their dad again but you can be damn sure
that they're looking up at that big
screen this summer and they're gonna see
detective Pikachu pika pika just me
[Music]
welcome to Ryan's City a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct if you were anything like your
talent
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah
yeah that didn't really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and not to
use this jeez here we go
I know you can't understand me but put
down the stapler or I will electrocute
you did you just talk whoa did you just
understand me oh my god you can
understand me but it's been so long
they tried to talk to me all the time
all they hear is pika pika you can hear
him right guys adorable you're adorable
they can't understand me kitchen no one
else I don't need a Pokemon period then
what about a world-class detective
because if you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
that brought us together and that magic
key is called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine yeah tell us what we want to
know pike yes okay I can shoving pushing
my problem is that I push people away
and then hate them for leaving he's
saying you can shove it what I can shove
it okay that's it no we're switching
roles I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
you